have you been tetr sized the simple
building game of falling bricks Square
rectangle trapezoid Teto has captured
hearts and Minds Tetris challenges the
mind and puzzles the imagination and
popular culture the Chevrolet Traverse
offers 44% more maximum cargo space for
decades this is what all those hours of
playing Tetris were
for now a 13-year-old has our fingers
itching again
oh my God Willis Gibson Who games by the
name of blue scooty is believed to be
the first person to beat Tetris his
screen froze I can't feel my fingers he
basically got to the point where the
game had no more memory to actually run
anymore and at which point the game just
crashes and and basically just ends the
accomplishment is rocking the gaming
world all my feeds is just like the same
thing like everyone's going crazy he
already had three milestones in this one
record so it's wildly impressive just
the fact that he reached level
157 I think is honestly absurd Philip in
is one of the best Tetris players in
Canada he says Gibson's age doesn't
surprise him more and more young people
are playing with great success I had
already thought the limits of the game
were already reached and this shows that
there are new heights that have yet to
be reached what's more surprising the
game finished was Tetris designed to
have an end no the tetris is not
supposed to have an end so the fact that
they got there is yeah it's a kind of a
miracle it's poetry art and math all
working in magical synchronicity it's
it's the perfect game his story turned
into a Hollywood movie last year Hank
Rogers is responsible for bringing
Tetris out from behind the Iron Curtain
still fast friends with the Russian game
designer over dinner Wednesday night
they Mar mared at the 13-year-old this
kid is amazing I mean like what an
accomplishment uh you know this game was
released in 1991 like how many years
before he was born is
that though at a reported 20 hours a
week Roger says he's not so sure he'd
let even his own son play his game for
so
long I'm pass out Abigail Beman Global
News
Ottawa